hello everyone and welcome to the fourth
game of the match all there is a future
vs Magnus Carlsen of the Magnus Carlsen
Invitational Alireza is now in a
must-win situation after Carlsen won
Game three the result is now 2 to 1 in
Carlson's favor and Alvarez and needs to
win the game to take the match into
Armageddon so what what will happen
let's let's check it out Alisa still
sticks to e4 but Magnus now does not go
for c5 he played at almost exclusively
in in the bathroom blitz Cup and in the
previous games but always always somehow
prevailed and now goes for a 5 as an
Magnus only needs a draw so he will in
fact go for the Berlin defence so Knight
to c6 Bishop to b5 we have the rule opus
and now Knight to f6 the Berlin defense
is on the board which is not not a bad
choice if a draw is all you need with d3
and now Bishop to c5 with Knight to c3
and d6 now Bishop to g5 just continuing
development h6 and here are white trades
on f6 with Bishop characteris Queen
captures and Knight to d5 now so giving
up the bishop pair but you get an
excellent outpost for the knight on d5
also threatening the capture on c7 so
Queen has to go back and now before it
is possible as the knight is pinned here
so Bishop back to b6 and there is one
game where Bishop to d4 was played but
then you just get c3 and then the bishop
goes back so magnet instead goes
immediately Bishop to b6 and it is as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game so ali reza continues with c3 i
just strengthens the center here that
also guards that b4 once again prepares
a4 a5 we have a six and now Alireza
first grabs the strong dark square
bishop with Knight capture seek actress
and now brush it back to c4
b5 pushing the bishop further back
Bishop to b3 and now both players Castle
with castles castles and Queen back to
f6 now as there is no more knight on d5
we have looked at a1 in just continuing
development and Bishop to e6 now Magnus
offers a trade of light square bishop
and a four by ali riza so a very tough
position for ali reza to push for to
push for something we've looked a to c8
and now as the c3 pawn is a backwards
pawn so you you wouldn't mind for
example doubling up rooks here so ali
reza decides to open up the a file with
a captures a captures and now Bishop
captures on e6 with Queen captures and
the Queen - E - yeah so now we have this
position where Magnus has a double beep
on however even though it's it's not all
that all that great he does still have a
favorable position here as White has
these two points which are also some one
week and if you go oh you cannot go ruk
to a7 right away as the night covers the
a7 square so rook F to d8 Magnus with
ideas of pushing d5 with h3 and now as
white allowed it d5 finally black gets
rid of his backwards pawn ich Actress
and rook captures and now this pawn will
be a target we have Brooke a2 b1 ali
reza has to set up a defense around the
d3 pawn and Magnus will start attacking
it rook C to d8 rook the d2 preparing to
double up on the D file in now Queen to
d6 adding yet another attacker we have
worked to be one and now Queen back to
g6 so now you can see that why it's
pretty much doing only moves that guard
the d3 pawn and it's not something it's
not a position you want to be in when
you're in a must-win situation in a
match so here ali reza shifts the night
over to e 1 and magnus continues with
king to each 7 now i just improving the
position of the king Knight the c2 one
prepares the shifted over to e3 and just
work the d7 magnus just waits for all
arrays of to do something as I think
I'll Reza was down to one minute here
and Maryland says over 4 minutes so all
it is is the one who's low on time and
he's the one who needs a win so 93 and
just wrote back to d6
other days it goes night to f1 and
Magnus just repeats rook to d5 and here
Magnus is basically saying that if you
want to draw here I'm down with a draw
as that means I win our
so Queen to f3 Alireza of course is not
interested in a draw night the d8 now
Magnus also wants to improve the
position of his knife he wants to switch
it over to e6 and then perhaps the f4
and now comes h4 and now cousin has to
decide whether he wants to allow h5 or
push h5 himself he instead goes h5
himself and now Knight to g3 with a
double attack here so you you either
play Queen to g4 to trade here or you
will Knight the e6 which is also a very
interesting idea then then for example
if you go Knight the e6 then if you go
for a capture here let's say captures on
h5 then efore is deadly because the
Queen cannot help her with the defense
of the night and also if you capture you
just lose a lot of material here so it
would be just just resigns here for
white
so instead Magnus goes for he doesn't go
for a knight to e6 which would prevent
this capture but instead goes Queen g4
he's done with the Queen trade and ali
reza accepts it but not in the way that
he should have here he played Knight
captures on h5 eliminating the defender
basically winning upon but much stronger
was just capturing the Queen and then
going in night to f1 and once the night
comes to e3 it will be incredibly strong
and this is this is the way white hat
white hat proceed
however he instead one for Knight
captures and now okay you grab upon but
now you allow Queen captures and pawn
captures and your pawn structure is now
ruined and you still have the same
weaknesses to worry about
so Magnus now went Knight to the e6 we
have night to g3 and now Knight to f4
just massively improving the position of
this knight Knight to e4 going after the
g5 square and now just b6 if if the
knight ever comes to c5 so b7 is not a
target
c4 oh it is a needs to create some
counter play here we have worked the d4
now just threatening to capture trade
and well any trade is goes across ins
way and now c5 by fallujah now whatever
you do future
the past pawn but whether he will be
able to keep it is a different question
so rook character son before we have C
character son b6 and now rook here
defending it and although you cannot
defend the pawn you do have nice to d6
which will win you the f7 pawn so Magnus
captures we have Knight captures on f7
and now Magnus doesn't go for Knight to
h3 check which is which is a way to win
the pawn right away and then you start
pushing your past be pawn instead he
goes for a sneaky tactic Knight to g6 he
attacks the h4 pond twice now he invites
Alireza to push h5 which he does and now
Magnus goes for root f4 he's trying to
give up the whole night for well only
temporarily for rook captures with
checking if one Andrew characters he
wants to trade down into a rook endgame
with equal material and of course Ali
Reza knows that that means that the game
will end in a draw so holidays --i
continues with Knight to g5 check king
h6 now attacking the white knight here
and Knight back to e4 but now Knight the
h4 by Carlson and going after the f3
pawn which would come with a nice fork
so King to f1 but now still tonight
captures an f3
we have worked the c2 getting the rock
out of harm's way and now King captures
on h5 and now it's Magnus who's up upon
but I Reza it was the only way to
continue if Ali resum I would not settle
for a draw so rook the c8 and there
could be some counter play with the
night covering these two squares the
rock coming to h8 who knows what might
happen but Magnus not impressed he just
continues pushing his passport so King
eat you first
and now b3 we have looked to be one
blocking the passport and now b2 not
doing the same mistake as early as in
the previous game where you didn't push
the pawn all the way so so Carlson does
it and now comes look the c5 going well
pressuring the e5 pawn we have Knight
the d4 check King to f1 by viola days
and now Knight back to f3
Magnus just says even though I have this
beautiful pawn here I'm very happy with
a draw however by repeating Knight to f3
he actually allows all it is that I go
after the point as a while the knight
was on the
for he was covering the C 2 square so
here
Magnus just decides to trade pawns rook
the B 3 and here of course a pawn for a
pawn but now night the night the c5 and
here both the rook is under attack and
here Magnus play tonight the D for
attacking all it is is rook I will
however invite you to I don't know if
you if I should even ask you to pause
the video here because the line that
that exists here is just a as I usually
say disgusting engine line but if you
feel like it you well you're welcome to
try and pause the video and try to find
this idea and if not I'm just gonna show
it to I think this one is for everyone
to just enjoy the show but in case
anyone tried and fine I found it then
really congratulations it's just a just
a beautiful idea instead of cousins
night to d4 move there exists a route g4
and it looks incredible as you give up a
whole rook here
however after Knight captures the rook
here rook to g1 check King to e2 and now
knights the d4 check you first give up
the night as well Knight captures and
now rook captures and b1 now the problem
is your knight is under attack and also
there's the threat of rook e1 check
followed by a promotion of the Queen so
if you don't want to lose even more
material then you need to you have to
play Knight f3 allow rook to e1 check
Knight captures and now you bring your
Queen into the game and now it's still
very hard a queen against the rook and
the night but you would definitely have
some chances with our leaders are being
so low on time but this is a this is it
would be asking too much for anyone to
find under any time control well okay
maybe nothing classical but here
definitely
so instead night before going after this
and also Magnus was a really playing on
time as I Reza was extremely low on
clock so there is a trades here tonight
captures we have Knight captures and now
he picks up the pawn rook captures here
but now Knights the e3 check King e2 and
rook captures an f2 check a nice little
trick that forces are an ending where
Magnus is just up upon so if you pick up
the night you lose the rook
so King captures and now tonight's the
d1 with a nice fork king of three and
night capture son b2 and now we have the
same game where Magnus is just up up the
Jeep on so King if we're going after
this point but now g5 we have d4 by alla
daisa if you go King captures here then
Knight captures and d3 comes with check
and then it really becomes complicated
so instead Fallujah gives up the pawn
here with a captures on d4 Knight
captures this way he gets the night into
the game and now g4 we have Knight to f3
and now g3 king f4 we have g2 and now
King to g3 and here night to d3 by
Magnus there is no no point in trying
anything as the Jeep on will fall so
king characters and g2 and it was in
this position unmoved for a 64 that the
game was drawn as it is a draw by
insufficient material so that's game for
for you I do hope you enjoyed it
this means that Magnus wins the match by
a two and a half to one and a half there
was a lot of crazy stuff going on any
game could have gone either way which
which most of them did and it was just
really a really a wonderful match to
watch so I do hope you enjoyed it as
well as I've covered all four games and
now we are continuing to the other match
to see how how Hikaru and diri did yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank florian Fisher for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus invitational most
likely until it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day